these three young men have traveled a
long way to be close to their idol the
German city of Trier where Karl Marx was
born has become a place of pilgrimage
for Chinese tourists he was a pioneer of
communist Chinese the Chinese government
would like to give this marks statue
reaching more than six meters tall to
the city of Trier to honor the 200th
anniversary of Marx's birth the design
made by the well-known sculptor
professor Wu Wei Zhang impressed trio's
mayor Nicky Bob the guys that we Kazim I
was thrilled when I saw the quality of
the artwork that Professor Wu wants to
give us it has nothing to do with the
typical Stalinist representations which
have somewhat influenced our view of
Karl Marx
but he had planned to accept it without
consulting trees residents and it's too
much for them it's too big it doesn't
suit Trier there's not an appropriate
spot smaller would be better for me it's
nothing more than a personality cult
it's just another advertisement that
Trier can use for its commercial
interests people living in Trier the
oldest city in Germany are proud of
other things for instance the oldest
well-preserved Roman city gate the Porta
[ __ ] or the important Christian
pilgrimage site st. Matthias Abbey where
the apostle Matthias is buried to help
City residents gain an impression of how
large the gift from China actually is a
wooden representation has been made the
city is certainly not shy about
promoting the statue and the wooden
portrayal is erected in the heart of the
city despite the weather six meters 40
including the pedestal
and there's been a lot of interest while
mayor LIBOR canvasses for the artwork
the artist in China is even channeled in
via smartphone we'll all of this effort
win over Trier citizens when you see how
China deals with freedom of the press
and Human Rights you really have to stop
and think about whether you should
accept a gift from China somewhat
smaller than this size would be more
acceptable to me it's good to mention
there will be people who like it and
those that don't
we will never be able to convince
everyone about it residents still have a
few days to express their opinion about
the large present from China the City
Council is due to make its final
decision next week